لدينا وصول حصري داخل الخندق
من خلال اللقطات التي شاركها
الجيش الأوكراني مع نيك بايتون والش
الموجود هناك، وهو تقرير
ستراه أولاً في المقدمة، أريد أن
أحذرك على الرغم من أن ما أنت على وشك رؤيته
الليلة هو  رسم بياني
حتى أن إنقاذ الموتى يمكن أن يكون عملاً مميتًا،
إنه فجر في المواقع الروسية التي تم اجتياحها حديثًا
على الجبهة الجنوبية حيث يتم
الهجوم على شبكات الخنادق المنتشرة
في العراء،
هذه لقطات نادرة تسمح لنا برؤية
وجهة نظر جندي أوكراني
وجسده  جامع الممثلة الممثلة
وحدته المكلفة بإعادة
القتلى الروس،
ويبدو أن هذه الجثة الأوكرانية قد
ذابت تقريبًا في الأرض، والحرارة
تسرع الاضمحلال، وهو عامل آخر في هذا
العمل القاسي حيث غالبًا ما يتم
توجيههم إلى أهدافهم  الرائحة
التي لا توفر الأقنعة حماية
كافية منها،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك، أوه
نعم، تراهم
الطائرات الروسية بدون طيار ويشاهدونها
مرة أخرى
بنادق مضادة للطائرات بدون طيار، وهو تطور حديث في
حرب الخنادق من القرن الماضي،
إنه عمل مرهق أثناء قيام القوات
التركيز هنا على البقاء والاحتماء،
ويجب على بيتيسلاف وفريقه حمل هذه
الأعباء الثقيلة والحيوية طوال طريق العودة
إلى الطريق حيث يمكنهم بعد ذلك
إغلاق فرصة
الدفن والوداع
قبل أسبوع في جزء آخر من
الخنادق.  حيث كان القتال
شرسًا بشكل واضح، يمرون
بالدروع الموردة من الغرب والتي تم تمزيقها،
بقايا أوكرانية تم العثور عليها أثناء
القصف المستمر،
اشترك في
البحث، ولكن في هذه
المواقع التي تم الاستيلاء عليها، فإن الروس حذرون في فحص
كل مكان بحثًا عن ألغام
للرجال الذين يشغلون الموقع ليلًا
ونهارًا.  جامعي الجثث راحة مرحب
بها، حيث يزيلون التذكيرات بمدى
اقتراب الموت من
الأجانب، ولا يزال الروس يبحثون
عن أهداف هنا بين الرجال الذين ينقذون
الجثث الروسية، وهو
عمل لم يرغب أحد على
الإطلاق في القيام به في العلن بينما تصلي أوكرانيا من أجل تحقيق
اختراق
في الخارج.
الارتياح أنهم لا يشعرون هنا بأي شيء
مقارنة بالعائلات التي قد تشعر
ببعض الألم والانغلاق من
البضائع التي يعودون بها إلى ديارهم.
نيك بايتون والش CNN zapparizio أوكرانيا